in this problem an engineer is reporting
on fully turbulent flow in a pipe
flowing at 15 cubic feet per second they
know that the pipe is 500 ft long and
1.5 ft in diameter they also observe a
3-ft drop in the energy grade line over
the course of the pipe however they have
lost their notes on what the Darcy
wepack friction factor F is calculating
this they find that the friction factor
is about
X where in this case we are solving for
the Darcy YB friction Factor so the
first thing we have to do in this
problem is use our reference manual and
search for
Darcy this will bring you to page 313
first where we can get the equation for
the Darcy YP friction Factor so that's
going to be HF = f * l over D * v^ 2
over 2 G where HF is the head loss in
feet f is the Darcy wispack friction
Factor L is the pipe length D is pipe
diameter and V is the velocity G will be
gravity so we can immediately start
filling out some terms in this problem
we can see that we have a 3ft drop in
the energy grade line so that's going to
be our
HF so that's 3 feet we're solving for
the friction Factor so we don't have
that yet we know that L
is 500
ft and
D is given as 1.5
ft we do not have velocity yet
and then
32.2 fat pers second squared is our
gravitational
acceleration this is just a good value
to have
memorized So currently we need to solve
for V what can we do to get that we know
that there is a flow rate and we know
that there is a diameter so in this case
it's very easy for us we can simply do Q
=
VA solve for V = Q over
a this
equals 15
CFS area of a circle is going to
be
Pi 1.5 is our
diameter be
squared over 4
and this gives us just about
8.5 feet per second
oops which we can plug in to V up here
so if we do
that got
8.5 be per
second squared
so solving this out we can see even just
with the units that this is going to be
feet squared over seconds squared all of
that over feet over second squared so
we're going to be left with one units of
feet here these two are going to cancel
which means we are only going to be left
with feet on this side and feet over
here that will cancel Darcy ypack is in
fact a unitless value and if we were to
solve for this all the way
out the friction Factor is going to
be just
about
0.08 and that is all you need to do to
solve this problem we have to start with
our two
equations we have to recognize that the
3-foot drop is our head
loss and we have to recognize that we
can find velocity given the flow rate
and the diameter of the
pipe uh but yeah that's all it takes to
solve this problem